[Music]
[Applause]
bank Corrections of course a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show right so far many challengers
no winners we don't make mistakes
well tonight a fan with the YouTube
screen name j-rock 34 thinks he's caught
a mistake
he says the mistake happens at the end
of every fan correction when we put up
the web address telling fans where to
post their videos now you see instead of
using a backward slash we use a picture
of slash the rock guitarist it's kind of
a little joke we do it just to amuse or
ever yeah well here's j-rock 34 s video
hello maestro and Andy there's a mistake
in your sash in your code Oh / haha I
found an error if you think you spotted
an ever on our show reported it team
koco.com / ah hi I found an era in fact
the forward slash is the proper way to
do an HTTP address so therefore I feel
that you should have slashes head tilted
slightly forward to resemble the forward
slash thank you
thank you for shooting that underwater
that was nice of you that's first time
we've had somebody that and what is
obviously your jerk off camera
we come on battery need to see the whole
thing
oh it's poor night here on the show well
sorry j-roc 34 if that's your true name
but you're dead wrong
our slash is perfectly correct as it is
here to explain why is our resident
expert on the Internet
professor a you don't have to tilt a
slash so much because in the picture is
already me looking forward
that's a forward slash back slash would
be this let's go forward slash back
slash alright so sorry j-rock 34 but you
don't know about HTTP
[Applause]
oh and at j-rok 34 if you had trouble
following slashes response maybe this
version will feel more familiar to you
sorry j-rock do you know about HTTP
addresses
to the consu fans if you think you've
spotted an era on our show reported a
teen koco.com slash slash ha ha I found
an arat we will sort it out right here
on the air let's see if you've got what
it takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro
[Applause]